D
FOREST AND SEND THEM FOR MONEY
AND YOU KNOW EXACTLY WHAT THIS
IS GOING LOOK UP OLIVIA.
WHAT CAN THE REST OF US AND THE
OTHER 49 STAYS LOW FROM WHAT IS
HAPPENING IN CALIFORNIA.
VICTOR SPENT HIS LIFE THERE AND
IT'S BEEN THERE FOR GENERATION
IS WITH THE HOOVER INSTITUTE AND
WERE HAPPY TO HAVE HIM JOIN US
NOW.
PROFESSOR THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
COMING ON, IT SEEMS LIKE TO ME
WHEN YOU GET DOWN THIS PATH,
WITH THE GOVERNMENT DECIDES THAT
CERTAIN RACES OR CERTAIN
ORIENTATIONS ARE BETTER THAN
OTHERS YOU FIX IT?
>> I DON'T THINK YOU DO.
YOU LIKE YUGOSLAVIA, AND WHEN
SOMETHING IS NOT SUSTAINABLE IS
NOT SUSTAINABLE.
WHAT YOU ARE LIKE TUCKER IS
PREDICATED ON PRETEENS.
ONE WAS SILICON VALLEY'S BIG
MONEY INFUSIONS.
AND NOW THEY'RE LAYING OFF
PEOPLE AND COMPANIES ARE FLEEING
BECAUSE OF THE REGULATORY
ATMOSPHERE 45% OF THE LATINO
POPULATION -- MANY OF THEM ARE
UPWARDLY MOBILE, AND THEY'RE NOT
ANALYZING SOME RAINBOW COALITION
WITH THE 5% ARE
AFRICAN AMERICAN.
THEY ARE AGAINST REPARATIONS AND
MANY OF THEM ARE STARTING TO
BECOME MORE CONSERVATIVE.
IN THE SO-CALLED WHITE
MIDDLE-CLASS AND
UPPER-MIDDLE-CLASS AND
ENTREPRENEURIAL CLASS IS READING
AT THE RATE OF 300,000 A YEAR.
AND THAT'S WHY WE HAVE THE
HIGHEST TAXES INCOME AMONG THE
HIGH SALES, THE HIGHEST GAS
TAXES, AND YET WERE HAVING A
$25 BILLION SHORTFALL.
THESE TYPES OF PROGRAMS SO IT IS
NOT SUSTAINABLE, AND I DO NOT
KNOW HOW YOU CAN STOP IT.
BECAUSE I DON'T SEE ANY WAY OF
STOPPING IT.
THIS IS JUST A VENEER, WE RATE
IN THE BOTTOM 10% OF SCHOOLS, WE
HAVE THE HIGHEST PROPERTY CRIME
MATES IN SAN FRANCISCO.
WE HAVE ONE-THIRD OF THE
NATION'S WELFARE RECIPIENTS.
40% OF THE HOMELESS.
21% LIVING BELOW THE POVERTY
LEVELS, WE HAVE ABOUT 40% OF THE
EAGLE ALIENS IN THE NATION.
SO IT'S ALL BEEN A GREAT EVERY
CHANGE FED BY SILICON VALLEY
MONEY, AND UPPER-MIDDLE-CLASS IN
1% PAYING 50% OF THE INCOME TAX
AND IS COMING TO A CLOSE.
AND THEY'RE RUNNING OUT OF
MONEY.
>> I WONDER IF THEY KNOW THAT?
>> Tucker Carlson: I HATE TO
SEE THEM GET TO A POINT WHERE
THEY HAVE TO SELL THE STATES
NATIONAL RESOURCES TO KEEP
GOING.
SO LAKE TAHOE TO ARIZONA.
BUT IT SEEMED LIKE THEY ARE AN
EXPRESS TRAIN TO THAT PLACE IS
ANYBODY IN LEADERSHIP UNDERSTAND
THIS?
>> NO I THINK THEY'D RATHER BE
CORRECT, AND WOKE, DEBBIE
PROSPEROUS AND INCORRECT,
BECAUSE WE ARE SITTING ON SOME
OF THE LARGEST GAS AND OIL
DEPOSITS IN 50 STATES AND WE
HAVE THE RICHARDS ABBOTT
CULTURAL SECTOR IN THE WORLD, WE
HAVE ENORMOUS RESOURCES AND
TEMPORARY MINING AND WERE NOT
USING ANY OF IT IT'S OFF LIMITS
AND WERE TRYING TO DESTROY THE
AQUACULTURE SECTOR BY CUTTING
OFF THE WATER.
WE HAVEN'T REINVESTED IN THIS
WONDERFUL INFRASTRUCTURE OF THE
LAKES AND THEY GOT THE
HIGH-SPEED RAIL, $15 BILLION
BOONDOGGLE IN STONEHENGE COVERED
IN GRAFFITI UNFINISHED THAT THEY
DO NOT WANT TO DO WHAT WOULD
SAVE THEM.
AND THEY GOING OVER THE CLIFF
LIKE LEMMINGS.
>> Tucker Carlson: I WISH YOU
WERE WRONG BUT Y